[Musique]
bonjour merci donc je m'appelle pierre
leyrolles je suis directeur de recherche
à l'inserm et vous inquiétez pas je veux
pas vous faire un cours de biologie mais
je voudrais vous présenter la bio
impression 3d alors tout le monde
connaît l impression de 3d de de
plastique de pièces en métal ou d'autres
matériaux mais imprimé du vivant ça
c'est un challenge et la meilleure façon
de l'illustré c'est luc besson il a fait
en 1997 avec son film le cinquième
élément
donc on voit ici deux bras robotique qui
aiment prime successivement le squelette
les tissus et fabrique un individu en
entier comme ça où ça a l'air très
facile et ça a l'air tout à fait
plausible mais la bio impression ça n'a
démarré qu'à en 2004 aux états unis et
nous annonce nous avons démarré en à peu
près il ya trois ans donc ce cette
technologie qui consiste à imprimer des
cellules vivantes dans le dégel est
juste à son be1 à son début par rapport
à ce qu'on peut faire en biologie et la
difficulté que l'on a avec les tissus
humains et avec les organes a fortiori
c'est que dans mon doigt ici là dans le
bout de mon doigt g 1 milliards de
cellules
donc il faut beaucoup de ses nus et en
plus ces cellules elles sont organisées
dans l'espace à l'échelle de quelques
dizaines de microns on y trouve des
vaisseaux un capillaires sanguins tous
les 100 microns et donc il faut pouvoir
les organiser dans l'espace à l'échelle
de cette cellule et pour qu'elle puisse
se développe alors ce film a bien
illustré ce qui était la bio impression
dans le futur mais voilà ce que nous en
faisons nous faisons aux laboratoires
ont l'impriment couche parcours
dégel est dense et gèle on met des
cellules vivantes et donc là on peut à
fabriquer un objet qui va ressembler
comme ici au bout de mon nez mais la
difficulté c'est que ce gel qu'on va
imprimer il faut que les cellules elle
reste vivante à l'intérieur qu'elle se
multiplient qu'elle se différencie en
différents sous types cellulaires et
éventuellement si on a plusieurs têtes
d'impression
on va pouvoir imprimer des vaisseaux en
même temps qu'on imprime un bout de
cartilage comme dans le nez ou un bout
d'os et éventuellement si on veut
régénérer de l'osce voilà donc ça c'est
le résultat
ce qui nous intéresse est ce que je vais
vous montrer aujourd'hui c'est deux
applications de l'impression 3d ou de la
bio impression 3d en médecine un des
problèmes que l'on rencontre après un
traumatisme une promat au logis sévère
ou après un cancer des os par exemple
c'est une perte de tissu osseux
tellement importante que le chirurgien
doit essayer de le reconstruire
soit en transférant un morceau d'os donc
en transférant un bout de la fibula avec
son pellicule vasculaires et on comprend
bien que cette technique de chirurgie
présente des inconvénients
d'abord le greffon haut ce qui va
prélever ne s'adaptent pas parfaitement
aux défauts sont ensuite va falloir deux
sites chirurgicaux et ça va entraîner
des douleurs et une mobilité sur le site
de presse il faut savoir que l'eau c'est
le tissu le plus transplantées chez
l'homme après les transfusions sanguines
un million de transplantation osseuse
chaque année en europe
c'est quand même aussi là c'est plus que
la peau c'est plus que d'autres tissus
et bien sûr les organes tels que le
coeur les poumons c'est des chiffres
beaucoup plus bas mais bien sûr
on le sait on a besoin de donneurs et on
a besoin de trouver des organes et la
bio impression 3d
peut-être dans le futur si on arrive à
maîtriser tous les concepts biologique
de l'organisation d'un tissu et des
cellules dans l'espace on pourra
éventuellement refaire des open donc
aujourd'hui les chirurgies à transplante
de l'os et essayent de reconstruire des
grandes fosses nous nous avons choisi la
bio impression 3d et on imprime des
pattes de phosphate de calcium pourquoi
du phosphate de calcium parce que c'est
le minérale osseuse et on peut à partir
d' images scanner fabriquer des objets
de formes complexes qui vont s'adapter à
l'anatomie du patient comme ici un
biomatériau qui va s'adapter sur l'os de
la mâchoire
on peut contrôler la forme mais on peut
contrôler également la porosité pour
laisser le tissus cicatrisés à
l'intérieur et d'idées sa cicatrisation
et on peut contrôler et bien sûr sa
composition et ses propriétés mais nous
avons testé ces biomatériaux imprimés 3d
avec des cellules souches
ici vous voyez envers des cellules pour
la cultiver sur ce biomatériaux et ses
cellules et se biomatériaux si on les
plante sous la peau de souris par
exemple elles vont former de l'osce
il va y avoir un os en verre ici sur sur
sept fous piste au logis on voit la
formation de tissus osseux avec du tissu
adipeux au contact de ceux biomatériaux
3d et à partir de ces résultats on a
envie envisager de reconstruire de
grandes fosses e et avant de passer chez
l'homme évidemment il faut travailler
sur des animaux et donc on est on a
travaillé sur une brebis et vous voyez
ici une brebis qui est qui passe sous un
qui parle dans un scanner le même
scanner qui utilisait à l'hôpital et on
va scanner sa patte ou plus exactement
l'os du métatarse avec on voit ici la
vascularisation et à partir de cette
image scanner 3d on va fabriquer des
guides de chirurgie
guînes de coûts qui vont s'adapter
parfaitement à l'os de la brebis et à
cette brebis seulement puis on va
fabriquer un biomatériau 3d qui va
remplacer la perte osseuse que l'on a
créé et voilà les étapes chirurgicale
alors évidemment c'est de la chirurgie
c'est pas beau à regarder mais c'est ce
qui se passe tous les joueurs l'hôpital
donc vous avez ici le l'incision la mise
en place du guide chirurgicale avec les
les encoches pour pouvoir s'y yellow ce
de façon bien parallèles
ici vous avez là la partie osseuse
compte que l'on peut imaginer malade et
qu'il faudrait enlever
et puis vous avez ici l'eau sectionné
avec son pellicule vasculaire avec le le
pellicule vasculaire qui conte aura
isoler le biomatériau 3d qui correspond
exactement à l'os qu'on a enlevé et la
reconstruction après avec une plaque et
des vis d'ostéosynthèse pour tenir le
temps de la cicatrisation et voilà le
résultat
delà de cette reconstruction osseuse
d'un défaut de trois centimètres et demi
normalement un défaut comme ça ça ne
peut pas régénérer tout seul une
fracture sa régénère dans 90% des cas
mais un défaut de 3 cm et de miss c'est
beaucoup trop grand pour pouvoir
cicatrisant et le le biomatériau il va
servir de support à la cicatrisation et
on ya ajouté un pellicule vasculaire
pour apporter la vie à ceux biomatériaux
et vous voyez ici donc la cicatrisation
de l'osce qui a assuré la continuité de
de sa de cette régénération haut niveau
historique on voit ici des coupes
histologiques du défaut du défaut laissé
vide il ne cicatrisent pas on voit l'eau
sept ans rose ici et donc vous voyez
qu'il n'y a pas de cicatrisation quand
on ajoute le biomatériau 3d on observe
une cicatrisation osseuse et quand on
ajoute un pellicule vasculaire un
vaisseau sanguin qu'on a isolé sur le
site
eh bien on régénère davantage le tissu
une autre application de la bio
impression 3d
c'est laid elle concerne les tumeurs
osseuses les tumeurs osseuses c'est une
maladie rare heureusement parce qu'elles
touchent les enfants les jeunes
adolescents ça représente à peu près 150
cas par an par rapport au cancer de la
prostate 70000 ou le cancer du sein que
70 milles sait rien et donc les boîtes
pharmaceutiques elle s'intéresse pas à
ce cancer qui touche les enfants mais
malheureusement ce cancer il a un très
mauvais pronostic parce que certains
cancers très agressifs et on peut le
voir ici sur sept ce scanner l'humérus
est atteint et donc il ce patient va
rentrer dans un protocole qui consiste à
une polychimiothérapie c'est à dire
qu'on va on va donner de la
chimiothérapie mais à tous les patients
on va donner la même chose et ensuite
après plusieurs mois on va envisager la
résection chirurgicale de cette tumeur
dans un cas comme ça malheureusement ça
risque d'être une amputation et en suit
une chimiothérapie
c'est au secondaire qui est également
stable
malheureusement un tiers des tumeurs
sont résistantes à la chimiothérapie
un sur trois et ça c'est du à
au fait que chaque tumeur est différent
elles ont toutes des origines génétiques
différentes et ensuite il y à un cercle
vicieux qui s'installe entre les
cellules cancéreuses et les cellules de
leur micro environnement
donc on a eu l'idée de partir d'une
biopsie une biopsie de cette humeur
cette biopsie allait réaliser
systématiquement à l'hôpital
mais au lieu de la deûle a fixé de faire
de liste au logis nord la garde vivante
et on peut la bio imprimer cette biopsie
dans des boîtes de culture vous voyez
ici vous à on a fait des petits carrés
de deux gènes avec à l'intérieur un
petit bout de cette ue et à partir de là
on obtient
ce petit carré là qu'on a grossi 1 qui
permet donc de cultiver en trois
dimensions les cellules tumorales mais
également leur environnement campion et
vous voyez ici envers les cellules dans
le gène qui sont bien vivantes et qui
peuvent proliférer
après quelques jours de culture on voit
que ces cellules ronde au départ ici
déjà s'étale après quelques jours de
culture
elle s'étale à l'intérieur du gel ce qui
est un signe de leur vitalité mais
également elle se multiplient comme vous
pouvez le voir ici il ya plus de vert
que l'acs est que la donc ces cellules
ne se multiplient en trois dimensions et
donc on peut utiliser cette technique
pour faire un ce que j'ai inventé un
chimio g on connaît les antibiogramme
pour les bactéries un trouver le
meilleur antibiotiques pour une
infection données eh bien on a essayé de
faire un chimio g c'est-à-dire d'adapter
la chimiothérapie à chaque cube et pour
ça on utilise donc la bio impression 3d
et on voit ici sur ce résultat d' une
manip du du labo que par exemple le
cisplatine du moins les cellules que la
doxorubicine et donc on peut dire pour
ce patient il faudra utiliser plutôt de
la doxorubicine pour attaquer cette une
et on continue à travailler sur la bio
une pression mais là non plus de l'eau
sous un petit bout de tumeurs ce que
l'on souhaiterait faire ses imprimés des
organes aux ide ou des bons d'organes si
vous voulez sur des puces ou des lames
de microscopes sur une lame de
microscope on pourrait imaginer imprimer
un petit bout d'os un petit bout de
cartilage un petit bout de x et à les
relier ensemble avec un système de micro
fluide et l'intérêt de cette technologie
c'est de pouvoir tester les médicaments
de tester des médicaments sans avoir
recours à l'expérimentation animale de
le faire avec des cellules humaines
d'impatience 1 ou d'un patient malade et
donc on peut imaginer tester des des
maladies ostéo-articulaires c'est ma
spécialité comme l'ostéoporose que vous
avez entendu parler ou la polyarthrite
rhumatoïde et pour finir ma présentation
je voudrais illustrer un petit peu où on
en est aujourd'hui dans le bios print et
le bio printing c'est certainement le
futur de la médecine mais
malheureusement on a besoin d'ingénieurs
comme vous de biologistes comme moi et
puis de médecins qui vont pouvoir
utiliser cette nouvelle technologie à
l'hôpital chaque jour pour arriver à en
faire un succès merci
[Applaudissements]